bye
[Music]
hi good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
um
welcome to the planning committee
meeting today i shall be chairing the
meeting today my name is alan powell
um
first asked if we have any apologies
yes chair
apologies have been received from
councillor d roof
councillor dee hancock and councillor
jay ridgeway thank you chair thank you
and i should have said before then that
we have two applications to consider
this afternoon um along with reports on
planning appeals and on planning and
enforcement
um i'm happy with this and intend to
consider the business as stated on the
agenda
um are there any other apologies from
anyone on the floor
a non-received chair thank you
and second item is declaration of
interest which is formality that we go
through at every meeting
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interest and or other
interests not already on their register
of interest
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
do any members have any interest to
declare
non-received chair thank you very much
um
we now move on to item three minutes of
the last meeting
um we have some minutes in front of us
or sent to us
from our meeting held on the 17th of may
which wasn't all that long ago really
was it um
are we happy that these are a correct
record if so can somebody propose
thank you that's proposed by cancer
armitage and seconded by cancer elliot
now those in favor
thank you the motion is carried
um that brings us on to the main
business of the meeting
um but before we start i'd like the
clerk
to explain to the benefit of members
members of the public and those watching
on youtube
how we will deal with the applications
today over to you
thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the applications this afternoon
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
the legism's agenda supplement
has been published on the council's
website
and hard copies have been circulated to
you
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
after this the chair will ask the
speakers to address the meeting
each of the speakers will have three
minutes to put forward their views
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions if necessary to clarify any
points they have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on an application the chair will open up
the meeting for debate by the committee
and ultimately determination by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
after a speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the chamber
but they will not be allowed to
participate further from that point
similarly those who participate by zoom
may continue to view the meeting but
they must remain muted and turn their
cameras off
so that they too play no further apart
as you're aware this meeting is being
live streamed and a recording will be
placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy it
thank you chair
let's move on then to our first
application this is a
section 73 application
pursuant of 1 8 stroke 0 0 8 0 1 stroke
fl
to very condition two brackets approved
plans and brackets to ersamine or
azamine i don't know whether i
pronounced that correctly high stairs
lane stratton um in line with our normal
procedure i'm going to ask the planning
manager mr kirkham and officers to tell
us about any late comments that have
been received and to give a brief
presentation showing pictures and plans
of the site and i will allow the
officers to complete the presentation
consequently members could you please
reserve any points of order or questions
about the process until the end
there'll be plenty of time for you to
ask questions later on
mr kirkum
thank you chair
the application on the agenda afternoon
chair seeks consent to amend the
location of a previously approved
dwelling position approximately six
meters to the north
and slightly to the west of its approved
location
the dwelling is otherwise as consented
save um a minor alteration to the
fenestration on the west elevation
and the dwelling that has been permitted
previously share that remains extant
with the
consent granted partially implemented by
the construction of a dwelling
in view of the consent in place the two
primary issues members will need to
assess this afternoon or any additional
impact caused to the character of the
area and or any unacceptable impact on
residential amenity
in this regard chair officers conclude
that whilst the building would move
closer to more fields due to the blank
elevation facing it and the single-story
nature of the proposed dwelling when
viewed from more fields the impact is
acceptable
the recommended conditions chair are set
out in your report however should
consent be granted i would like to
review the previously imposed conditions
and reimpose any considered still
necessary as members i'm sure be aware
that any consent granted this afternoon
would need to stand alone
just in terms of
the
presentation show i won't
repeat um what we saw at the site visits
yesterday
but just to go through a few slides the
application site as his customary chair
is at the center of the slide and it's
colored in beige and you can see high
stairs lane just to the north of the
site with the a61
almost to the
right hand side of the slide
the application
site chair outlined in red and as i've
mentioned previously consent has been
granted for the construction of two
dwellings on this site one of which has
now been constructed as we saw yesterday
the
application
that was approved and we're looking at
only the
plot one which is the right hand side of
these two plots but previously consented
in the position outlined in red on the
slide shed so that's what has an extant
consent and you can see that part of
that
crosses over where there's an existing
building that would be demolished
and the application seeks consent to
move that dwelling to a position that is
then shaded in so to the north and
slightly to the west as i've said
the details as we saw yesterday
they are
the same as those previously approved
chair but with the detailing on the west
elevation slightly amended
to have an additional upper floor window
and the two center windows at the lower
ground floor they are
two halves of what was a double window
previously consented
and there's just a couple of photographs
chairs aid memoir this is taken from the
center of the site and you can see the
bungalow in the in the background there
that's one of the
two consented dwellings so that's been
erected and the bungalow to the
left-hand side that would be demolished
to make way for
the new unit which would be on the
application site in the foreground
and then just finally chairs we saw
yesterday this is just a photograph
taken looking towards the site from the
west from a public footpath and you can
make out in the
middle distance the the dwelling that's
been constructed and then you can just
see
the
bungalow that would be demolished to
make way for the the further unit
thank you chair
thank you mr kirkham um
i'm now going to invite speakers to
address the committee
um as the clerk has already explained
they will each have three minutes to get
over that points
and will be informed when thirteen
thirty seconds remain
um as members you can ask speakers to
clarify any matters that have been
raised
but remember your question should only
relate to the points that have been
already made
um i would now like to ask our first
speaker stephen ross
who is objecting to the application to
come and address the committee and if
you'd sit at the table there
and if you would press the button in
front of the microphone and the light
should come on to say it's red
thank you you've done that
can you confirm that this is your name
and that you understand the process
yes
if so you have three minutes okay
okay
um i live at moore fields to the east
person mine
which stands around
25 meters from where it
is
from from us
when it's demolished the new one
would be about eight meters from us
and if this application goes through
bring it down to four meters from us
the reason is
the site was never big enough to
accommodate these two
enormous properties
the application
as a result
was a resort of an oversight by the
family
doing the development
um
that when the old bungalow is demolished
they'll have nowhere to live
although the sun has built his house
already and they've been living there
for a couple of years
and i was astonished that the
development ever got to go ahead
given all the reasons
for its refusal in the first place um
reasons such as
planning policy seeks to ensure
the dwellings are not materially larger
than the one
it replaces
or has a greater impact on the setting
um
that development would be in congress
in scale massive design
and orientation
these are some of the reasons given
the refusal in the first place of this
application
um
overall
the proposals would result in
significant harm to landscape
environment and countryside
being contrary to policies gs1
gs6b1 h3 and ne1
for the northeast district council
local plan
and policies ss1 s9
sdc12 and sdc3
of the local plan
how many more years do you need
so what changed on appeal
we bought our house in 2004
after viewing it
and being wowed by the views to the west
over the umber valley
this will all now but disappear
for us the damage was done when
permission was granted on appeal
for the 30 seconds
all we ask is that the permission that
was granted that appeal
stays as is
from the start our concerns have never
been considered
so we're just asking for some
consideration
as the damage to us has already been
done
thank you um have any members any
questions for the speaker
[Music]
councillors
mr ross could you tell me where your
house is in comparison to me it's to the
east
yeah that's like on the opposite side of
the road
no no no no it's
over the hedge over the edge right okay
thank you okay
anyone else
no thank you thank you
[Music]
i would now like to ask mr joseph rolls
or rolls apologies if i've got that
wrong as well
who is the applicant to now address the
committee
can you confirm that this is your name
that you understand the process yeah
that's my name joseph rolls and i do
understand the process thank you you
have three minutes
thank you i don't have much to say but i
just wanted to thank you for the time
today to consider this um variation to
the
size of the plot to the location of the
plot i mean
um as you're aware we've completed plot
two
um and i'm living in that property now
and
it's been well received by the residents
of the lane
um we've had some very good comments
from our neighbours
um having completed that house
we started to plan out the second
property and we quickly
realized that we'd overlook the fact
that this property is much closer to the
field
than the property that i live in
um this
is creating much smaller rear garden
than the front garden the front garden
is much larger than the rear
and because it's um the way it's been
set it's actually offset on the plot
um
so we've took some uh council
we spoke to our architect the planning
consultant and the planning team here
and we looked all the
benefits of moving the plot forward
and we came up with these benefits um if
we move it away
from the open field boundary that'll be
a benefit to the countryside
it will straighten up the building line
with plot two
it will increase the distance between
the house and the countryside which i've
already mentioned
and it will centralize the property on
the plot which increases the rear garden
and makes it much more in proportion
because it is a family house
i'm looking ahead it will be a family
house i know my dad mum will be living
in it for a while but
looking ahead it will be a family
property
we have taken into consideration the
other properties around the site
and we have concluded that this move
will not adversely affect anyone in any
way
so overall
i think the feeling is that the proposed
new layout on the site will be much
better for the environment
the landscape and the overall layout of
the finished project
i trust this makes sense and enables you
to support this amendment if you've got
any questions i'll
try and answer them
thank you mr rose has anybody got any
questions counselor elliot
thank you chad
could you tell me where from last
speaker that the house currently with
what you was proposed to be built is 21
meters from that boundary and if you
move it it's going to be
four to eight meters is that correct no
the
i think what um mr ross is referring to
is the current property that's on the
site
that's being removed that's 25 meters
away
so
we are moving the property slightly to
the north
but it makes very little difference as
we saw in the drawing but the one we
passed plans for originally how far away
from that property does it
will it say it or would it have sat
before this move
so we're moving the property the whole
property is moving by approximately six
meters
so i'm not sure how big mr ross's garden
is but there's a strip of a four metre
strip of land between our property and
then his property which is a strip to
the
to field to the boundary not to the
property
sorry
between our our pro our boundary and
neighbours boundary there's actually a
strip of land which accesses the field
on the in the rear right and then
there's his garden right and our
property is two meters from the boundary
right
there you can show it on the drawing
again
yeah if you could bring up the drawing
agent that'd be great thank you
just to to try and help them chair
um the
property that
mr ross
says this property this is more fields
and as the as we saw yesterday there's a
field boundary
a field access running down here where
the harris fencing was
up against and then
in terms of the
property you can see what was approved
is is the red and then what is
proposed is
outlined sorry
that lines
you wrote it here
adrian can i just confirm them that if
this bungalow is moved
back
or if the original one is built it would
be built closer to mr ross's and if we
move it if we allow it to be moved back
in the field
towards the field
let no check just so
yeah absolutely clear the one that has
consent is outlined in red
right that's the one that's permitted
and the one that is proposed is it's
that one so that's the the blocked out
one
actually the shaded one was the uh now
it's the other way around the red
outline is the one consented and the one
that's blocked is proposed and you can
see that mr ross's property you see i'm
afraid i don't have the
exact measurements chair i'm afraid but
that's that's the property that
mr ross has spoken to about
yeah and then
so his property is
approximately here
it will be towards mr ross's property
yes thank
thank
you
thank you councillor any other members
uh against foster uh thanks chair yeah i
suppose my concern with this and i'll be
careful i would uh i would describe this
mr rules but
you originally asked for planning
permission it was granted uh for one way
which is now the other one that's in red
and i could see that going through
maybe if you'd have come with uh this
one as it's proposed now we might have
looked at it different so that's my
immediate
thoughts on the matter
uh that's just my thoughts first my
question
is uh you mentioned about wanting to
move it and after you've took a counsel
and said that you wanted it more in line
you want it in the center of the plot
it's quite obvious when you look at it
initially
even from the very beginning that it's
not in the center of the plot to give
that as a reason now i've wanted to move
it
it's very similar to placing it well
outside the plot in another counter and
then now wanting to put it in the plot
it's that different it's obvious back
then so that's my first question uh what
year uh what are your thoughts on that
why do you suddenly why did you suddenly
realize once you'd get got planning
permission why did you
realize uh it wasn't in the center well
that's the first question
so yeah so yeah you're right um
we didn't we always plan to do plot two
first
um because that's the house i've moved
into
um and when we actually came to mark it
all out we realized that the garden is
going to be smaller
um
so yeah i mean we should have noticed
the beginning and we should have
actually spoken to the architect about
it alistair haxton but um he put forward
the proposals and we let it go through
so i think it's an oversight from when
we're actually doing original planning
i take the attitude that you answer mr
rose it's an oversight although
i've only looked it for a very short
time it looks like no oversight from me
from the very start that's i think
that's that's clear to me anyway
and the second one is about the four
benefits she mentioned uh which
accounted can't recall them all uh some
of those about centralizing the putting
it in line
um and that it wouldn't affect uh the
amenity of anyone so he said conclude
they won't affect anyone um
but we've obviously heard from uh from
the neighbor uh the first chapter that
spoke mr ross that it does affect his
immunity so it's not entirely fair to
say that so you should comment on that
please that you want to thank anyone
else obviously it's going to affect mr
ross um i think the way we looked at it
and we took council on this that
um
where they have where the property is at
the moment
and
if we move it back the the view we do
accept that building our property where
it is going to where it's initially got
painful now that will affect mr ross's
view
but
if the house is in that position or in
the in the new position
it makes no difference because the only
window i believe is is a dormer window
at high level which looks over the top
of property so whether the properties in
location a or location b it won't make
any difference
i won't press it too much further chair
but just enough to say that it obviously
affects mr ross's
view
and i believe that's why he's here
but thank you for the answers thank you
anyone else have any questions for mr
rose
no
thank you thank you
right as per our normal procedure
you'll now have the opportunity to put
questions to the officers about the
application
um again um as
the
uh the real chair of the planning
committee will always say
i would like you to keep this part of
the proceedings focused on getting
clarity about the points you're not sure
of
once we've done that we can then have
our discussion on the application that's
when we will debate it
and based on all that you have heard and
read
and and i would be grateful if you would
not move any motions at this stage let's
wait until we've had a chance to
conclude the debate
um
so therefore uh members have you any
questions for the planning manager
cancer
armitage thank you chair
well uh you
showed us the uh visual
adrian but you didn't show the
photograph which you had
at the site meeting yesterday the one
that shows uh
mr ross's
the view
and his dorm window which you had
yesterday perhaps you put shows that
again
because i think it it shows uh
the uh
effect of the immediacy value of
mr ross's house and how it will be
damaged by this proposal
whilst the planning manager is looking
at that um i would remind you um that
the loss of you is not a planning matter
there's nothing in the planning
system that allows for that um and i
we would then have to identify what you
mean by immunity
yes
is the um the photographs chair that we
we saw yesterday it's not our normal
practice to reprise them but
um i'll just go
through them
um
and come to the one that cancer armitage
i think is particularly referring to
there's the um that's what we saw as the
the entrance into the site
yesterday and you can see the this is
the
the field entrance that we discussed
yesterday
and the the application site then in the
middle
distance and just getting to the one
that i think that council armitage
particularly was was raising reference
so this is the
and so that's mr ross's
property and you can see the the dormer
window in the upper store and then the
windows in the the ground floor you can
also see chair the the changing levels
and the hedges that that we saw
yesterday i think that's the one that
yeah cancer armitage in particular is if
we go back to it
where it's photographed from is actually
lower ground
so
it isn't just the uh window the dormer
window it's the windows lowered down you
just see the top of them uh now if you
turn it on the same level or take it
from uh mr ross's side
it would you would see that uh
that would be the whole
length would be obstructed by
moving this uh building forward
and that's my point is that
the uh
we know that uh loss of view isn't a
planning matter but it's the meanest
value of it the gentleman bought that
house uh
with the immensity of it and
you know
just moving this
site for the site forward
it's going to stop all of that and but
if
it remained where it is
uh if you look at the plan the block
plan
it will be
behind a number of very large trees
uh which will shield it from mr ross's
uh
molly's garden basically
and
you know i think that it's far too near
to the boundary
uh with the proposal
and it will be better where it was
i mean they should have realized when
they did it
that uh
you know
okay the garden's gonna be a bit smaller
what's your question to the officer
cancer hermitage well it was the fact
that
we didn't see the correct photograph
which shows the actual uh
the dormer window one of the most
salient facts of this planning
application
thank you councillor foster
uh thank you chair um
at the beginning mr kirkham said the two
things we've got to consider the impact
on the character of the area and impacts
on residential immunity i don't have any
difficulty with impact on the character
of the area compared with that's that's
already thinking being i think that's
already been covered in the and the
first application that was granted i
think that for me anyway that satisfies
me that part uh but the impact on
residential immunity i'd like some
further advice from mr kirkham on what
uh our chair mentioned earlier now
we understand the loss of you isn't it
isn't always a plan in consideration but
the uh the impact on residential amenity
perhaps if we can have
the the we could have a further
explanation on that
uh
because to me
i understand it that that a view can be
in that uh amenity it can be not solely
on that but it is to do with and it's
connected with that
um
that's how i've always understood it
before
so perhaps a better definition from mr
kirk
to give us more advice on that and what
we're able to rule on thank you just in
relation to that chair and um
jenny may have something to say on this
if i if i get it wrong she's uh she's on
zoom and will correct me if legally i
get this wrong but
my understanding share is that the loss
of you is not a material planning matter
so the fact that somebody may be able to
enjoy a particular outlook
and the loss of that by development
wouldn't be a material matter but just
in terms of the point that counselor
foster is making amenity would normally
be for
a planning consideration to be impact on
the general amenities so so for example
if there was a large building at the end
of your garden that you currently have
light looking over a hedge and there was
a two or three-story building at the end
of the garden you might consider that an
impact on the the amenity of the garden
you would certainly
assess manatee and amenity in terms of
how
a building whether it be a new building
as in this case or an extension how that
would affect living room windows so
kitchens um lounges and other primary
rooms that you would expect a level of
light and what we would
bundle up as amenity to be associated
with and you would look to protect that
so it it's those sort of areas that we
would normally associate amenity with
not
impact of you so you've mentioned
overbearing overlooking would all be
within that in this instance chair from
from the officer's point of view we've
taken
our stance on it on the back of the fact
that the proposed elevation that would
be closest two more more feels his
single story there's the hedging in
between and it's more feels at a
slightly higher level than the site
itself
and the other element we've taken into
account share is the fact that the
opening closest to moore fields is is a
garage so there wouldn't be any direct
window to window
issues so that's the reasoning that
officers have taken but of course as in
all cases chair members will need to
take a view as to whether um you you
similarly see it in that form where you
take a different view
hopefully i've got that right and jenny
uh hasn't got any clarification chair
but i'm sure she'll come in if
yeah that okay that is correct
residential immunity it's not defined in
law and it's just uh elements that are
particularly relevant to the living
conditions of a dwelling so in essence
that's what it is
thank you
any other questions for the offices
thank you chair
um
to the east um where the where the
where the road is between the the
properties
there's a there's a dense area there are
trees or shrub
um
how dense is that and
and if this was to be granted
would it aid the situation if if there
was some further planting
i could probably best best answer that
for cancer groups yeah sheriff i just go
back to the
the um
the photographs chair and that's the
first one that counts for armitage asks
for so you can see
a hedge on the site boundary and then
behind the harris fencing that's the
field access and then the
hedge behind there
and then
further around that's the the group of
trees that are referenced on the drawing
so they're
in position so
the the site proper you can just see
behind the vehicle here there is a a gap
in the hedge
so
there may be um facility to plant that
up and you can see on the block plan
that's indicated on the the drawing that
that would be
um
completed so the two
bits of missing hedge there you can see
what the the left-hand element of that
towards the other one could be
be filled in
it may help chair but yeah i think you
would need more than just
just hedging and it wouldn't provide an
immediate
screen and of course if you if you've
got
vegetation
growing to a to a
height that would potentially have an
impact on moore fields as well as much
as any building but of course that the
planting of trees shrubs wouldn't in
itself share required planning consensus
certainly wouldn't normally be any
control then over the height they could
go through planning anyway i hope that's
helpful
thank you councillor cooper anyone else
right well we now um
come to the final part of our
consideration of this application
um and the discussion about what we've
heard um and what we think and what we
want to decide
uh before going any further i'd just
like to clark to remind us about motions
thank you
yes thank you chair
please bear in mind members that a
motion must be moved and seconded before
a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved in
seconds
then the amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations should comprise
the relevant planning issues and be
supported by the evidence as necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendation falls
or in other words it is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations or a
different course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
in terms of the timings of the motions
these should be moved and seconded after
the committee has heard read and
discussed the evidence before it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached and will then invite
invite motions to be put
members will be reminded of this by the
clerk if they wish to propose a motion
before then
thank you chair
thank you to the clerk for that um
and i like to open the floor for debate
um again as the clerk is just reminding
us could you please refrain from moving
an emotion until we've had concluded our
discussion
i'll open the floor
cancer elliott then cancer armitage
thank you chad
i was on the committee when we passed
this back in the day
and i was only happy about it because it
was going to be
built into the bank of the land into the
topography of the land and it and it did
give
no overbearing or no overpowering
feel to the properties around it i
wasn't totally comfortable with it but
it was the best we could get from it um
it may have been an oversight for the
back garden
but i don't think in i i don't like the
fact that it's moving six meters forward
just to give a bigger back garden and
close some well someone else's property
and making it overbearing and
overpowering for the people that live
there
thank you chair
yes
thank you chair
i think one of the things that
it's a very very prominent site and this
was uh you know as uh council aliens
pointed out it
it was sort of the
best of a bad job that we got it
that we passed it
and i think moving it forward
uh it's like uh counts earlier
it will impact on the uh neighboring
property and
i don't think that uh
well i'm not happy with it let's put it
like this to be going forward like that
you should be where we packed where it
was passed and it should be left there
if you look at it from a distance
uh
it's got the backdrop of those big trees
and you don't see it
it doesn't stick out like a sore thumb
like it would do if you moved it where
there isn't a backdrop you can mention
about planting trees
but
the tree screen is already there and
it's mature
if you'll go and
move it forward you're gonna have to
plant those trees and it's gonna be 20
years before you're going to get an
effective screen
i think we should leave it where it is
council foster
thank you chair um
it's that this is this for me it could
be it could be one way or the other for
me but when i think about
those four benefits uh that have been
mentioned by by mr rules
uh i can see those benefits but the the
benefits to himself and to the property
um
and then i think about mr ross and his
situation um and he is obviously
affected and there is an impact there
and he can see it coming in advance
then my initial thoughts on it
um and then i've settled where i often
do settle someone's right to do what
they want in their area on their ground
with their building they finish where
someone else's rights begin i find and i
think what's happening on this piece of
land is affecting uh mr ross on on on
his piece of land so he's got a right to
enjoy his his residential
uh amenity uh i do take office's advice
and that uh
that they don't think that this uh this
is uh the case
uh that there's no an acceptable impact
on the immunity of neighbours uh but for
myself uh the first part that we had to
consider impact upon the character of
the area no but certainly impact on
residential immunity uh for myself
especially after the uh the explanation
we've had about elements to the living
conditions of the dwelling
um
you know how we've had that uh described
by by officers so i can see that it does
and we've had the uh the chap himself
saying it doesn't it does affect him and
you take people on uh on the word
um
and yeah anything else would be
repeating what my colleagues had said so
thank you chair
are you counselor foster anyone else
right um
mr kirkham do you want to comment on
anything that has been said in that
debate before i ask for motions
no chad um happy to take any further
clarification but
nothing i would wish add that
uh right um well having heard and read
everything today and the office
recommendations before us
what's his review of the committee on
the application so i now open the floor
to a motion
against armitage
yeah i'd uh go against uh officer's
recommendation on this and the effect of
the immediate
on this
could he be a bit more specific
it's going to uh
you know it's going to uh the living
conditions uh of the gentleman next door
i think it
will grossly affect his immediacy
mr gergin do you need any clarification
on the specifics of that immunity
element
in in um
framing uh
a motion shot and
the the adjectives that have been used
and in the debate are overbearing
overpowering prominent
impact on residential amenity it
to um frame a reason for refusal should
members choose to refuse the application
share if it's on those grounds it would
be
if any or all of those are appropriate
and of course
members are aware of your policy sdc 12
which
raises the issue of protecting amen to
existing occupiers so
again it would be my suggestion sheriff
members aren't minded to refuse the
application on that grounds in terms of
a policy you may wish to
hang that on that would probably be the
most appropriate but um without members
advising otherwise chair i would suggest
that
any reason for refusal would include the
adjectives
overbearing
and prominent i wouldn't recommend using
overpowering
and also the the issue about impact on
residential amenity and the living
conditions of occupiers of
um the property
health
apologies chair but i think it's the the
property of more fields that i think is
of concern to members
i'll go along with that
excuse me um do we have a second
chancellor foster
uh yeah happy to second that motion uh
if we include sdc12
overbearing prominent and that it's
affecting the living conditions of the
dwelling of more fields and impacts on
residential amenities happy to second
that chair
thank you right well we have a vote and
we will do this by real call just be
absolutely clear chair then so the
motion is to um reject the application
uh against officer recommendations
on the grounds that the property or the
the development would be overbearing and
prominent
go against policy sd12
in terms of the impact on the immunity
of the neighboring resident
at the essence of it
members sdc12 version
yeah apologies just ss1 ss2 ss9 and sdc3
so it's sd um c12 and the other policies
which just mentioned
okay thank you chip
so i'll now carry out the role culture
with
your permission
councillor armitage
councillor cooper
councillor elliott
council of foster
councillor hall
for
councillor hartson against
councillor liggett
paul
councillor jones
okay
council of powell against
councillor rouse
against
right sir
um
five
people voted family members have voted
for
four of against one has abstained
on that basis the motion has carried
thank you chair
thank you
right we now move on to the second
application
which is a retrospective application for
a garage with saw
at crofton vale
alton lane little more ashova
and again in line with our normal
practice i'm going to ask the planning
manager and officers to tell us about
any late comments reports that have been
produced
and to give a brief presentation showing
any photos and plans of the site
i will allow the officers to complete
the presentation consequently members
could you please reserve any points of
order
or questions about the process until the
end of the presentation thank you mr
kirkham
apologies chad i just need to
share my screen
thank you
firstly chair on um application 2200 244
i just referred members to the late
comments report that was sent out
yesterday
this application chair is seeking to
obtain consent to retain a garage that's
been erected close to and serving an
approved bungalow it replaces in part a
number of derelict structures and
buildings
primary issues that members will need to
address in this instance are the impact
of the garage and the character of the
area and any any impacts on neighboring
amenity it's important to note however
chair that any private matters such as
ownership are matters for the parties
and not for planning committee to
resolve or consider
officers have concluded chair as members
will note that due to the small scale of
the garage the materials used on the
distance from the neighboring property
of the garage is acceptable i'll just go
through a few slides chair but again not
to repeat what we saw on the site visit
yesterday
but the application site
is hatched and the garage sharing the
location in the western
corner and you can just make out the
buildings that formerly occupied the
site
albeit in a relatively poor poor state
when they were taken down the bungalow
that's been constructed is
extant and there's also the rebuilding
of this property again that's been
granted consent so both those are
authorized
there's the the application site chair
showing the the bungalow that's been
approved and then the replacement
dwelling that's been approved and you
can see the neighboring properties
next door whose gardens also extend
to the extent
where the the rear garden of the
bungalow
falls
so in terms of the detailing chair these
are depiction of the buildings that
formerly occupied the site
and then that's the structure that's
been constructed and which you'll see in
a second
you will recall yesterday's site visit
the query was raised with regards to the
wall to the rear of the site
and this shows on the right hand side
the bungalow that's been constructed and
you'll be able to see on the left hand
side
that the boundary wall has been
constructed of stone
and also chair and the photograph
of the the garage itself with the steps
leading to it and again you can see the
the rear boundary wall constructed of
stone and that clarifies the matter
raised at site visit yesterday but that
is the the structure that's been built
that's the garage
then finally chair that's a picture of
the garage from the front
and you can see the the bungalow has
been approved as being been constructed
but is yet unoccupied to the right-hand
side so it's the garage that members are
being asked to consider in this instance
chair
thank you
[Music]
thank you
can we have only one speaker who is
joining us by zoom um i would now like
uh thursday helen sanderson who is
objecting to the application to address
committee
hello
can you hear me
as we can hear you
right yeah we can see you angry
right um can you just confirm that that
is in fact your name and that you
understand the process that is correct
and i do understand the process thank
you
thank you you have uh three minutes
thank you for the opportunity to speak
the main points from a planning a
perspective of the negative ecological
visual and audio impacts caused by the
removal of dry stone features and
vegetation along the entire boundary
between the rear garden of oak road in
the crotonville plots
an overbearing two-story garage store of
an obscure shape has already been built
along the boundary
that building is of significantly
greater height and sits much further
forward than the dry stone outbuilding
that was originally sited on that
boundary
the garage door has been built with a
breeze block elevation facing oak road
the replacement boundary wall is also
breeze block which is neither
representative the character of the area
nor does it provide a habitat for
wildlife
the garage store now sits directly next
to a pond and waterfall the pond is a
habitat for wildlife including frogs and
newts and has been a focal feature of
the oak road rear garden for 27 years
with a seating area directly next to it
there are no soft landscaping schemes or
ecological documents submitted for this
particular 2022 application
the ecological and agricultural reports
for this site date back to the original
2016 application for the associated new
bungalow on the site at croftonville
despite being unaware of the ponds in
the locality those reports highlighted
the ecological importance of the
original dry stone walls and the
vegetation along the peripheries
the updated 2019 applications for the
new bungalow showed that the dry stone
wall adjacent to the okroid pond and the
waterfall would be retained with a new
hedge being introduced directly behind
it
one of the conditions of the 2019
approval was for the implementation of
the boundary treatments if this 2022
planning application is approved the
boundaries detailed in 2019 alongside
croftonville and okroid can no longer
exist
that hedge served two important purposes
from a planning aspect
the first being an ecological habitat
next to the original dry stone wall the
pond and the waterfall and the second
being a privacy screen for the two new
overlooking bedroom windows which
directly face and are close to the oak
road rear garden
those overlooking windows to habitable
rooms were introduced by the covent
developer in the 2019 application
the bungalow that was approved in 2016
had an integral garage and a utility
room closest to the oak road property
with only a small window for an ensuite
facing oak road
the new garage is now located at the top
of the croftonville plot with no
provision for replacements of
landscaping along the entire boundary
along with the visual character
ecological and privacy issues
highlighted there will also be a
potential for noise disturbance with
cars coming and going along that new
boundary
i am deeply saddened by this 2022
planning application had i been allowed
to comment before the building was
commenced i may have been able to
mitigate some of the negative impacts
thank you for your time
thank you
any questions for the speaker
counselor foster
uh thank you chair um
mrs sanderson's uh addressed quite a few
points so perhaps just a bit of clarity
on
something that's in our report uh you
mentioned about different harms to
uh to the area we've got an eight point
one uh it says to us and this is a
chance for you to perhaps uh
explain a little further where harm is
identified the application should be
refused so if you'd like to just recap
on some of those for me please so i can
take note of that absolutely
so for me and one of the biggest impacts
is the ecological effect of the fact
that the new garage is now wrapping
around a pond and a waterfall
previously which was cited there was a
dry stone wall and my mother and my
father and the lady that used to live
next door purposefully didn't put any
hard boundaries around that area they
installed a cement post with a fence
which the wildlife could come and go
between
and they put vegetation along the entire
boundaries so on the croftonville site
that used to be conifers
and rhododendrons and laurels and on the
on the okroid site it was again
rhododendrons and laurel hedging and
things like that and so that allowed the
the
um creatures from around that pond area
to come and go what is now there is a
solid freeze block wall with a fence on
top which is
a totally
um full boundary which will prevent that
wildlife coming and going there's no
vegetation at all down the entire the
southern boundary between oak road and
crawford and bell it's all been
completely stripped out
and and what has been put at the top is
now a a solid garage with which wraps
around entirely around that pond that is
one of the kind of important aspects for
me i was actually living at the property
when that pond and waterfall was built
by my parents and i actually helped to
build it and so i understand the
importance exactly from an amenity of a
residential
area of what that that that top corner
of that garden represents with regards
to the rear garden at oak road and this
is why it's deeply saddened um me in
particular because i lived there for 10
years
so that's one of the first points the
second point is is that it's overbearing
having lived there for 11 years i'm well
aware of what was what was previously
there it was a dry stone outbuilding
where the um the
site from the okroid back garden was was
very low and it was completely that the
roof had caved in um but the walls that
um reached up to the elevation actually
soaked away from the oproid boundary
um and um what's been put there now is a
um garage
where the actual an elevation right on
the boundary has been extended from what
was an outbuilding which is further
along into the crofton bell plots and
they've extrapolated the height of that
building which was definitively single
story not two-story and i have
photographs unfortunately with my
children in so i haven't shared them
that date back
27 years and showed the original roof on
that building that's that's
one small question on the back of that
hey again
uh
the approximate diameter of the pond
you're talking about mrs sanderson wow
um
probably about five or six meters in in
the width i did include photographs of
it in my original representation so you
i know you probably can't go back and
look at that now um
yeah i would say it's about six meters
in width um i can lie completely in it
and i'm five foot ten
if that's helpful um
in fact my husband can also lie
in it as well and he's six foot so um
yeah across the width of it i would say
it's about six foot and so about two
meters but um the kind of narrowest
point and then it's probably about i'm
not very good with this isn't it
probably about maybe
maybe four meters
in in the expense across the other side
and then there's a little waterfall
tucked behind it as well
thank you councillor
can i just ask you mentioned about cars
driving past yeah
can you tell me where the
original garage to that bungalow was so
it is in the ecological report from 2016
the photograph of it
and that's been included in the 2019
application they referred back back to
it the original garage on the plot
actually sat and behind
what is an outside and toilet and shed
on my
father's side so the okroid bungalow has
a little back gate and the toilet in the
shed was directly sort of next to that
perpendicular to the house and then the
garage originally was was
at the front of the plot directly behind
that that
um toilet outside toilet in the shed so
it was
in line with the garage
that is there now but further forward
now no so the original garage is a
stone-built garage that was right at the
front of the plots
um probably if you stood at the gate as
it is now and walked about
20 foot forward and to the edge of the
oak road um
um property that's where it would be i
don't know if you can pull up a
map of oak wood it would the corner of
the garage was was was next to the
corner of the oak road bungalow right at
the front of the plot that's where the
original stone um garage is and there
are photographs in the 2016 um
ecological report that show that it was
classed as i think building four i think
yeah so yeah
it was actually closer to your parents
bungalow
so yeah the original garage was so with
this is the original garage that was was
demolished because in 2016 it was going
to be an integral garage that was part
of the actual bungalow that's now been
built
but and the current developer decided
not to have an integral garage he still
knocked down the original garage and he
stared he's chosen to put the garage
right at the top of the plot which means
that um the cars will now go the full
extent of that southern boundary from
the road to the top of the garden before
the garage didn't was sat the entrance
to the garage and the garage itself sat
um before you got to oak road back
garden
okay thank you
thank you
more questions for the speaker
thank you
if you now put yourself on mute we'll do
thank you
questions to the officers um and
my first question is how far away is the
neighboring property from the garage
the the garage this has now been built
i think um perhaps the best way of doing
that chair fire i can bring up a slide
showing the next door property and it's
only taken from the street but hopefully
that will give you
a good understanding of
that
this is just a
street view image
jen you can see the
next door property here you can see the
new bungalow
built built here and the
is is back at the site so as we
um
and we saw
um yesterday this is the the taken from
the the garage door and this is the
bungalow that's
been built and that is
okroid that uh has been referred to
chair so the the property next door is
is
my words but hopefully it's it's a fair
and something got the property next door
is to the front of the site whereas the
bungalow and the garage is right to the
back
thank you any other questions from mr
kirkham
answer elliott
thank you chair uh adrian is that garage
built into a it doesn't really show the
the levels is that actually built into
the bank of it does it bank up at the
back
again share it if um just go back to the
the photographs yeah the answer the
question is that the site does
just rise to the rear when i looked at
the the new stone wall at the back it
looked like it dropped away as well but
it looked like it banked up to me
so
where it is it's less visible than the
original one
so for me should make the site look less
prominent i'm quite happy with that
just um
this photograph is probably the the best
yeah you can see that the garage is
is sat into the the lens it rises to the
back with the stone wall yeah that's the
one thanks adrian that's fab thank you
here's a question from mr
answer hermitage
have there been uh any comments on
derbyshire wildlife on this site and how
much bigger is this building than what
was uh
originally there
the the first
answer share is now there's been no
comments from darbjorn life trust we
don't believe we will have consulted
them on something of this at this scale
this size just in terms of the
the size chair i can do no more than
and go back again to the
the various
drawings that we had and that
to be able to see
[Music]
from the
[Music]
from that slide chair that is the
buildings that formerly occupied the
site so i and there's any dispute on
this the building that's
been introduced is larger than the the
ones that it it replaced
and as you've just heard it's uh
um
you can see there what was was there
primarily single story structure
but bearing in mind that the point that
we just discussed with
council eliot in terms of how the land
works there is that to be taken into
account as well i don't know how this
fell onto the site now the site may have
been modified subsequently you can see
from the outline here
there is a certainly a slope on these
these drawings that were submitted by
the applicant which suggests there was
some
levels change that's been undertaken now
to create the bungalow and the garage
that's set into the site rather than
perhaps following the the previous land
levels but i have no information in
respect to that i'm just surmising from
the drawings that we have
thank you
elliot
thank you thanks hey adrian there's been
a lot made of some block work as well
can you can you enlighten us on that on
the blockworks side of it because the
rest of it looks really well and
sympathetically done to me
the the issue chair is first of all that
the application that is before you is
for retention of the garage alone
and there has been significant comment
made in respect of other elements of the
of the site
and on the approval for the bungalow
there was agreement on boundary
treatments and i believe that has that
is what's taken up quite a lot of
um comment in the the comments made by
stakeholders that
as i read the application that is not
before you this afternoon and if there
remains concerns about the boundary
treatments then that would be a matter
that would need to be taken up
independently and i'm not not prejudging
how that will be judged
yeah
the boundary treatments
and certainly on the
on the representations which you may
have seen that have been submitted to us
on the okroid side of that wall there is
a finish in breeze block and there's an
element of the garage also a small
element of it that is also breeze block
now as officers first of all in terms of
the garage that's not something that we
have raised issue with we we feel it's
acceptable as the
majority of the building is of stone as
you've seen
and in terms of the issues regarding the
boundary treatments
that is a matter that may well be
between the parties
and we've not as officers pursued that
um independently but that my advice
chair would be that members judge the
garage on its merits this afternoon if
members are concerned about the boundary
treatments then that can be followed up
but there's an element of that i believe
that is for the parties to to address
that's great adrian and that's all i
needed to know i just wondered whether
it was part of the application or
whether it was going to be addressed
elsewhere but you've answered that fully
thank you
any more questions for the planning
officer
right we'll now move on um to the final
part of the process
um
[Music]
you're waiting for the next vic right
okay uh well we've got to the next bit
so off you go
thank you uh well to be perfectly honest
i know this property and i know it well
because i was as a little girl i used to
visit it with the old lady that lived
there before this development
and um i can assure you that the garage
that was there previously was a lot
bigger than that one and it was at the
front of the plot right next to um
mrs sanderson's
parents bungalow
it was a large double garage it was at
the front of the plot and it was in
direct line with the garage that's there
now at the front of the plot
um the outbuildings at the back
there was quite a few um they weren't
there like back in the day but
i can remember going to look at it when
when it went up for sale
um and
the derelict buildings there were quite
a few of them and they were very
unsightly
and it is like you say well built into
the bank it's much lower than the field
the field rises up at the back
the whole road slopes there
and so i personally i think they've made
a lovely job of it and i think the
garage looks really nice i'm not so keen
on the wall but that's a different issue
but that's my feelings thank you
thank you councillor in another comments
[Music]
okay right um i'm going to open the
floor to motions cancer elliott chair i
move officer recommendation
it's moved and seconded moved by cancer
elliot and seconded by cancer armitage
adventure with your permission i'll now
take the roll call
councillor armitage
councillor cooper
councillor elliot
councillor foster
councillor hall
for
councillor hartsaur for
councillor liggett for
councillor jones who's dane
councillor powell
four
councillor rouse
four
that's nine four and one abstention the
motion passager
um right we now move on to um
item seven planning appeals
uh now ask mr kirkum to explain our next
report appeals lodged and determined
chad the
most weighty element of this report is
of those that are appeals lodged and you
can see that there have been four
appeals lodged the two middle ones the
two by w red marlinson's limited chair
relate to a single site so they're going
to be dealt with by single informal
hearings they'll be lodged together
sorry chuck and i just interrupted this
point uh as we made clear yesterday
there was an error sense uh with the uh
the pack so you actually have a hard
copy uh with you now
apologies chair
we have subsequently chair had one
appeal decision
handed down to us and that will have
been sent on to members that will be
reported at the end of june
in conjunction with others that we may
receive in the time there are a
significant number of outstanding
appeals that we're waiting for decisions
on and they will start to come through
hopefully
in the next few weeks and as always
chair happy to take questions on these
or any other appeals and i'll answer
them if i can
any questions
no all right well um we now have another
item which is about enforcement
matters
um and i'm going to ask for the
officer's concern to be uh brought in
so uh we'll have a very short break
whilst we change personnel
obviously need a couple of minutes chair
but five minutes will be sufficient
certainly five minutes it is thank you
oh no has been significantly increased
recently so we've had more activity
um and i would like uh one of the
officers to explain it to us first
and then i'll open up the floor for
questions and discussion so first of all
welcome to the meeting um we've we've
had a fairly short planning meeting so
far
um
but
we will give you all the time you need
to explain what you've been doing and
the good work you've been doing thank
you
thank you chair my name is julian hawley
i'm the principal planning enforcement
officer
i've been at the council now for about
10 months i'm pleased to say i've been
made very welcome
there's a team of three
2.6
equivalent posts
and to my left here is fiona todd
she's the senior planning enforcement
officer and she joined the council in
september
and this is joanne edwards she's the
planning enforcement technician
and you've been here quite a bit longer
um but prior to both myself and fiona
joining the council the majority of the
work was actually dealt with by joe and
it's fair to say that we wouldn't be
where we are without joe's incredible
effort
thank you
um so the the sort of the process for
this is set out in the local enforcement
plan
and there's a commitment to report to
members on a six-monthly basis
setting out the work that the
enforcement team does
and giving you some relevant information
on the numbers of cases we receive what
we close
and also formal enforcement action taken
by the council and members will see that
in the report that we've produced
so just touching on some of the uh
most important points of it we've
obviously
only been here 10 months
and during that time we've been trying
to
whip our planning database into shape so
that we can actually start to produce
these reports without it being an
incredibly onerous task and
work on that's ongoing so thanks to our
planning admin team and support offices
have been brilliant
um
so just going through uh the the
previous year 2021 the financial year
we've received 358 inquiries in that
time
these are um
inquiries to do with a specific site or
a development and within those there may
well be numerous numbers of complainants
or inquiries
and so this this is an individual people
that we're dealing with that number may
well be considerably higher
the average over the previous years i've
just taken a few contexts was 225
so we've seen an 80 increase
in this last year in the amount of work
that we've been doing for the team um
and that's actually reflected across
lots of other councils we've formed part
of a garbage enforcement office group
and they're reporting similar
increases in numbers of cases that are
being dealt with
you know that's probably a consequence
of coming out of the pandemic some
people have got more disposable income
than others
um but also the way that people are
choosing to live their lives now has
changed significantly people running
businesses from homes or
putting summer houses and things in
gardens um
so that may well be uh
the reason for that
also as part of the work that we've been
doing we we do carry out proactive
enforcement investigations so that when
we're out and about in the district
looking at things we'll
you know call in at sites and check on
what's happening if there's things we
see we'll go back to the office and
check they've got planning permission
and if they have them we'll obviously
check that the conditions are being
complied with so that's part of a more
proactive
service which we hope which we're
intending to offer
um so
as i've said in the report we're you
know constantly striving to improve the
way that we store and retrieve
information
a lot of work's going on at the moment
in terms of getting an electronic
enforcement notice register set up
so at the moment that's just purely in a
paper format sat in the office it's not
really very functional for people
members of the public if they want to
interrogate it so
we're trying to combine our sort of
public access mapping system with
enforcement notice register
bring service improvements to land
charges and people wanting to find
information out themselves so
as you can appreciate there's hundreds
of notices stored in various places
which we have to retrieve upload make
sure they're properly presented
look at what the status of each of those
enforcement notices is whether it's
complied with varied appeals dealt with
those kind of things so
you know this is one of a number of big
tasks which we're doing in the
background to sort of streamline our
service and make it better and easy to
to um
you know deal with i suppose
so just going through the break the
breakdown of closures
we are actively trying to record exactly
how we deal with
um
planning enforcement inquiries
so the what we've managed to pull
together is to give you some idea as to
exactly
the reasons why we close inquiries so
that could be to do with the fact it's
not a planning breach
um and the report finds that about 40
percent of the work which we deal with
isn't actually a breach of planning
control
but each of that mean well because it's
permitted development something allowed
by the permitted development order
and but each of these has to be
investigated so it's still office of
time going out to look at it deal with
the people who own the properties and
deal with the people who are inquiring
and 20 of our workload is dealt resolve
with through planning applications so
um you know there is a right within the
planning act to make retrospective
planning applications for development
uh and those are the figures with you
know which have been
approved may well be a number which have
been refused and then that comes back on
our desk to consider for formal
enforcement action or whatever but
so hopefully members will find that
useful and we're streamlining that to
make sure that the information we
present is is
easy to understand gives you some
context
then just going to the end of the report
this is the formal enforcement action
which has been taken in the last
financial year
and we've just given you a little bit of
an update as to what the situation the
status is with those notices
so um a number at the moment have been
issued and are in the appeal process and
we're obviously dealing with the
planning inspectorate on those
we've had some success in terms of
taking direct action in some enforcement
cases and that's something that we'll
look to do more of in the future
so we're working with
the assistant director to put forward
tendering documents um so that we can
send out some tender proposals for
contractors to look to take direct
action on our behalf
and then just at the end there the sort
of other form or other notices which
we've issued in that time community
protection warning notices um and also
planning contravention notices but they
don't form part of the the planning
register and they're confidential at
this stage what we are able to disclose
is where we have taken formal
enforcement action
so hopefully that's the uh sets out what
we're trying to do and we'll report back
to you every six months with updates and
hopefully the more we go through this
process the more the information and the
numbers will start to make sense
um obviously you'll see
that we've got a significant backlog of
cases at the moment and we're
dealing with that backlog
as well as trying to deal with the
uptick in work that we've got so it's
there's a lot of pressures on us and
we're trying our best so
hopefully you found it useful and you
know welcome any questions or anything
anybody's got
thank you julian um
anybody wants a comment or question
counselor liggett and then councillor
foster yeah i just wanted to thank you
actually for what you're doing because
you've certainly helped me on numerous
occasions and particularly with
questions and about conservation areas
etc and
quite a few little problems we've had so
i just wanted to thank you very much for
what you're doing
well thank you very much that's really
appreciated
answer foster
uh thank uh thank you chair uh yes uh
thanks very much for coming along and
thanks for that report it's great to see
that as a first report
uh
if i add to it in 2019 uh as an
administration
we know we inherited a massive massive
backlog
of cases that need looking into
and uh without uh pointing fingers or
anything like that we know that at that
time we only had uh one part-time staff
so half
uh
half a person on on the job which is why
that backlog was there now we've got
that 2.6 you say uh yourself fiona and
uh and joanne
i can see that you are doing so much
work you could easily point at the 80
percent
uh with the increase there and you give
the reason
for this one of the reasons being
proactive enforcement investigation by
enforcement team i can see that and i
know that from people i've spoken to
it's that proactive engagement with the
community which has encouraged more
people to come forward so absolutely
and i do think we need more of that so
as well as proposing to follow
recommendations and note in this report
i'd like to propose a vote of thanks to
your team because i think you've been
absolutely excellent really and it's so
great to see it really is it's a it's
heartwarming it means that this uh you
know the people in northeast derbyshire
are getting a real service you know for
the money they pay for the taxes to pay
so you know on behalf of my residents
thank you very much i'd like to propose
that
um
before we
before we have it's not a notion i know
it's a proposal but before i have we
have that anyone else want to comment
can answer hermitage
well uh
all i'd say is that uh
both of them came
to us with quite a reputation and i know
where they came from uh
they were sorely missed
and i'm glad we've got you on board
and you're doing a great job between you
thank you
it's worth pointing out you know we are
part of a wider team and the support we
get from adrian and the planning
officers is absolutely incredible
so you know a lot of this is because we
work so well as a whole service so
thanks to those as well
thank you anyone else
well i'll just make a comment before we
actually go through the recommendations
and that is that
clearly things are so much better than
they were
but i would hope that
um well i know from the area that i'm in
that people now
realize they can't get away with things
and i would hope that your workload
diminishes
to be honest as people realize that you
know
let's not put that's not greeks and
regulations in the first place
i think there had been a
feeling that uh well we'll put that
illegal sign up and nobody noble bother
well we do bother now and i think that's
a very significant step forward
so what we have been asked to do is to
um
and note the report
um
and
and effectively approve it and you would
like to recommend that gas of hosta
i'd like to recommend that full
recommendations but i'd like it to be
recorded in the minutes of voter thanks
to this team please
with your permission share
right i think we can do that with a show
of hands can we i think so chair yes
everybody happy with that
right well thank you very much indeed
and thank you um to um to you julian
brianna and joanne
and
you have our absolute backing and we are
grateful for all the work you've done
and the structures and systems you've
put in place
thank you very much
no
next item is urgent business i haven't
got any age of business so i will thank
you for your attendance
declare the meeting closed thank you
you